Let's get right into audience questions for
the week, one that is increasingly coming
in in different forms.
Is would it really be possible for the United
States to vote by mail in the 2020 presidential
election?
I think one thing that's important is you've
got to reframe this question is what it actually
is, which is would all 50 states really be
able to vote by mail in the 2020 election
because you really have 50 state elections
in the 2020 presidential election.
So while the debate has been, Nancy Pelosi
says she wants vote by mail in November.
Trump doesn't.
And we know why Trump doesn't.
It would be bad for Trump for more people
to more easily be able to vote.
Trump, in fact, is essentially counting on
his supporters going out to vote.
But Biden supporters not going to vote maybe
because of fears of the Corona virus.
We don't exactly know where that's going to
be yet in November.
But for a lot of states, though, some states
already have vote by mail, states that don't.
What you're really talking about, you know,
they the right loves to make it seem like
this is this overwhelming task.
How do we go from no vote by mail to national
vote by mail?
Well, if you already have absentee ballots,
which as far as I know, every state or almost
every state does, you have to scale up the
absentee ballot program.
You've got to print more ballots in advance.
In some states, there are laws that say you
can't just send an absentee ballot to everyone.
People have to request it and then you are
able to send it to them.
I've argued that simply pointing at the policy
is not really proactive governance.
Instead, we should say let's pass something
that this year, because of extenuating circumstances,
you don't have to request an absentee ballot.
One will merely be sent to you.
And then it's just you know, we're talking
about a mass mail campaign, essentially.
So the issue of getting the ballots to people
could be solved if we start dealing with it
now.
The issue of printing enough ballots could
be solved if we start dealing with it now.
The economic cost of the postage is far smaller
than the economic cost of the election, potentially
escalating or causing a second wave of corona
virus infection.
And we've got about seven months to do it.
So the answer is yes.
The U.S. really could vote by mail in 2020.
But you would need to start that process now.
And it seems to me that especially appearing
to be past the peak on this first wave of
Corona virus, the political appetite for doing
that, especially from the right, is not going
to be enough to reach critical mass.
Now, sadly, if a second wave gets going closer
to the fall, you then may get a lot more people,
even Republicans, saying we've got to do vote
by mail.
We have to expand absentee ballot to everybody
in states that have absentee ballots instead
of vote by mail.
It probably will be too late by then.
That's the unfortunate reality.
By that point, the process of printing all
of the ballots, putting in place enough a
sort of public information about the fact
that this is the way it's being done, dealing
with the fact that many states have a rule
that you can only send an absentee ballot
to someone who has requested it.
You can't just start sending them out by then.
It will be too late.
Like if we don't deal with this, if on September
25th, we see that wave, two of corona viruses
exploding and we've got to deal with this,
it probably will be too late by then.
The question mark right now, the test case
is Ohio.
Ohio, you might remember, was scheduled to
have their primary in March.
They postponed it because of the virus, said
it would be done June 2nd have since changed
and said we're going to run sort of like a
nearly month long vote by mail campaign, but
until April 20th.
But everybody has to request a ballot again,
relying on this thing about we can't just
send the ballots, people have to request them.
So we will see in Ohio how it works in the
Democratic primary and then we'll see if there's
the political will from states to actually
do this now.
What you have to also remember is because
these are state decisions, you could have
a situation in November where the states that
are likely to be Biden states do the vote
by mail and Biden wins regardless.
And the states that are likely to be Trump
anyway don't setup vote by mail and they go
to Trump.
The difference maker, as usual, will be what
is Michigan do?
What does Pennsylvania do?
What does North Carolina do?
Those few states that end up making a difference.
And then it's anyone's guess.
This is one area where it's good that Michigan
has a Democratic governor.
It's good that Kentucky now has a Democratic
governor, because it could be the difference
maker in.
Do they vote by mail or not in November?
And thus does the election flip towards Joe
Biden or back towards a Donald Trump reelection?
Scary stuff.
A lot riding on it.